That was our stunning guest,
and our dear friend of the show Michelle Buteau.
And she is now in the new rom-com "Marry Me".
You did a lot of ad-libbing,
they would do takes and then give you the floor.
Is that true?
Yes.
If you hire a comedian then you should use them
for what they're good for and good at.
And so I love when I can go off script,
and just go ham.
My favorite is trying to break
the person I am in a scene with.
And so, yeah, I got Jennifer a couple of times.
Okay, tell me, because she seems like the funnest,
most amazing woman, I could not be on her feeder or more.
I am obsessed with J-Lo,
but she seems put together.
What's it like when she breaks?
This is what I love about doing comedy,
because no matter what lines you have in your head,
what to-do list you have on your mind.
Whatever you have to do
it's just pure joy that comes over your body,
sort of like a sneeze you can't control it.
Or like a fart, you can't control it,
but you know you feel better afterwards.
Hey yo, but the point,
I'm so sorry, what's wrong with me?
I haven't left the house in three years.
So the point is, yeah, it was really fun.
And you could tell she's busy, she's got a lot to do.
She is a business woman, she is running companies,
she's taking care of people.
She knows what camera angles could get our shot faster
to get us home for dinner with the family.
I like efficiency.
You guys also are both the mother of twins.
Yes.
What was that like to talk to someone
who also has been through an extraordinary,
rare, unique journey?
Yeah, it was really special.
I'm mean the main thing for me
was to respect Jennifer's space.
So I really acted like I didn't know that she had twins.
And I was sleep training the twins
while I was filming this movie.
Oh my God.
So I just came to set
one morning, exactly, what day was it?
And one eye was open I think,
and she's like, "Are you okay?"
And I said, "I'm sleep training my girl, boy twins."
And she said, "I have girl, boy twins."
I said, "You do?
I didn't know that J-Lo."
(audience laughs)
But I knew it.
I wanted to be like, "How is Max and Emmy?"
But I was just like, "Really?
Tell me."
And so, yeah, we shared tips and tricks.
And she had a lot of tricks, which was really nice, yeah.
Okay, so your book "Survival of the Thickest"
is now out on paperback.
Yes.
But,
please tell us what else just happened
with your phenomenal book.
Oh my goodness,
well, Netflix has acquired the rights to the book,
and so we're turning it into a TV show.
Eight episodes.
Can you believe it?
It's amazing.
Yeah, it is a dream come true.
Yeah, it's a dream come true.
I cannot wait for this show,
I need it now.
Okay, is it true that,
because I started a magazine,
and you had a magazine when you were young
called "Head Over Heels".
Oh my goodness, you do your research honey.
Yeah, I do, we do, good producers,
and we care so much.
Right.
So tell me about Head Over Heels,
your magazine when you were a young girl.
I created a magazine,
because I didn't even know what community was
but I knew that I craved for it.
And I was only eight years old,
and I started a magazine called Head Over Heels,
and the logo was horrible.
It was a shoe with a severed head in it,
I don't know, but you know what can you say?
And I would put it in all the neighbor's mailboxes,
and I thought I did a bang up job.
But the neighbors asked my parents
if I would stop leaving stuff in their mailbox.
And then also you had a talk show.
Oh my God, okay,
so I used to get girls together for Saturday morning,
because I wasn't allowed to watch cartoons.
Really, why?
My mom wanted me to be productive.
Oh.
I know, now I work in television.
But it was a Cabbage Patch and Inpound Puppy club.
It was very Hoda and Kathie Lee,
but with fourth graders about their Pound Puppies
and their Cabbage Patch dolls.
And you had to give stories and recipes,
and what outfits you liked, you know what?
It sounds like this show
by the way.
I know.
I was like, it's a lot.
(audience applauding)
The last question,
any advice for me as a talk show host?
No, I think you're doing all the things
that I wanna see in a talk show host.
Because people already know you,
and you're already America's sweetheart.
But there's this depth, and realness,
and quest for...
Knowledge and you're excited.
And you only want people to be their best,
because you wanna be your best.
Thank you for your service, thoughts and prayers.
That's made me emotional, thank you.
Come on girl.
You're so dope.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
That was not what I was expecting,
I thought there was a Pound Puppy joke coming.